oh it's that time for you to turn your
great idea into a reality with
guess who squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your
passion project whether you're
showcasing your work or trying to sell
products of any kind
they have beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about
anything so you can easily make a
beautiful website for yourself
by yourself but if you get stuck they
have 24 7
award-winning customer support that is
there to help so head to squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain make that dream
a reality get in there
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very exciting episode malcolm barrett is
with us today
he's an actor he's a he's a rapper he's
a poet
he's a friend of the valley folk you
might know him as rufus from nbc's
timeless
you might know him on one of steve
zaragoza's many
projects uh you might know him as the
artistic director of the ammo theater
here in los angeles
either way he's an amazingly cool guy
i'm excited for you to get to know him
if you don't
know him and uh we talk about all kinds
of things we talk about growing up in
brooklyn
moving to los angeles becoming and
getting in the world of poetry
um some of the most quote-unquote
interesting experimental theater he's
seen that includes
uh chewed up gum and heads and water
it's very artistic and fascinating so
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
malcolm barrett
[Music]
want to do some vocal warm-ups some zip
zap zop
it's already so wildly impressive to me
i know okay well that uh do you actually
do verbal warm-ups
verbal the rapper do you do audible
warm-ups you do vocal warm-ups or
anything like that before
you perform i do uh during oh good
there's a
there's a fighter jet above uh perfect
what set are you on
good yeah yeah i'm on the set of uh your
fortune
yeah okay so it's a reboot
uh but very popular right now um no
i don't really do vote well that's not
completely true i do vocal warm-ups um
more in theater but not a lot and
depending on like what the thing is that
i'm doing yeah
i play a lot of nerds so there's like a
lot of like
yeah you do yeah so like if i'm really
high i'll do vocal warm-ups just because
it's like it's easier because when you
get high then your mouth gets all dry
and whatever and so
yeah you want to feel comfortable over
enunciating without feeling weird so
like that's
so that's my advice to every young
that checks off the question of what
kind of advice you have for young
performers looking to make it
yeah well okay so you're in
you're in theater you're in traditional
acting you're in
music you're you're in arts this is what
i ask for a lot of guests that are kind
of like
hybrid performers what is what is your
deal
like how do you describe yourself to
someone that's never met you that wants
to know what you do
um what is my deal
uh
it's a little off-putting but i'm always
curious as to how people
i feel you have enough um good favor
that i don't nothing's that off-putting
oh good um um
yeah i guess so look if i was in new
york
i'd comfortably say i was an artist but
people don't really use that terminal
way
like probably the first um term i heard
in the industry that
never got used again yeah like because
they don't say artists too much when
you're
like in l.a like l.a like you're an
actor or you're trying to get a paycheck
like everything's paycheck
related right yeah yeah you know like i
hate to be all like
i'm a [ __ ] artist inside um but like
you know that's what new york is like
right like all these
yeah the visual artists painters they're
the teachers they're they're whatever
you do and they all consider them
artists for the most part so for me
when i was trying to find my voice it
just came out in whatever way it
happened you know i grew up
on hip-hop so i was rapping and
freestyling um when i was in high school
in junior high and having battles
and things like that and you grew up in
brooklyn right in new york
bedstock brooklyn biggie small stop and
brown um
literally near jay-z across from mercy
projects wow
yeah yes i lived in all the places the
black folks rap
about and all the places white people
drove through and now live
that's where that's where i'm from
so yeah i was heavy in the freestyle and
then rap and then when i got to college
it became
poetry at that new european poetry cafe
and so i was oh
wow plan poet but i was writing stories
since i was like in the first grade
so to me okay so yes i'm curious as to
what caught your eye with poetry because
that seems like a very
niche kind of world to enter as like a
young artist
like what was it about that um well my
mom wrote poetry
i you know yeah yeah my mom wrote poetry
i you know it was it was always an
interest it never
for me it never seemed that wild a thing
i i will say that
making it a vocation was an eye-opening
thing you know because
you know once i started going to nyu
then i started going to the lower east
side which brought me
to the eurekan poetry cafe cool so
that's where i started doing it
but then as i became a regular and was
winning competitions and joined the team
um i think the first time i joined teen
i was at ainsley burroughs
and he had all his chat books you know
we were roommates yeah we were
touring and he had these chat books and
i was like oh you guys are making money
off this because keep in mind i was
doing it before
deaf poetry jam came wow yeah this is a
world i don't know anything about so
when you say you made the team
what does that mean exactly so there are
national competitions for slam college
right okay um and so i was on a new
eureka national team in 2001
cool and then so you get sent to seattle
where the nationals happen i literally
got a poetic license with my name on it
oh that's so fun yeah so that was my
work
that was my world for for a while for a
couple years
um was that and and hip-hop you know i
was putting out a poetry album and
trying to work on chat books and but
then the acting thing took the music
thing i went to la and so it just became
a different world for me
wow yeah i probably moved to l.a right
before
deaf poetry gems started um because i
would have loved to have done that and i
was just
outside of that circle as it started
merging so what brought you out to los
angeles what brought me up to los
angeles was a show called luis
with luis guzman so the guy who wasn't
uh whipping his penis out
good classification yeah i'm sure he
would sit out on occasion like you have
to at some point
um that's just the nature of penis
but i'm learning so much and we're five
minutes into this
as i can i don't know how long
um so so yeah so i did a show called
luis
with luis guzman he pronounces it in
many different ways
um i was in school at the time um
but my my experience in college was
always somewhere between
me actually doing the things that we're
doing like trying to learn and take all
these things
and actually working outside of her
school like i was
acting outside of school at the same
time
yeah so but louie was the one that made
me leave school because
i got the pilot mitt shot in l.a
wow so i mean and that's also so you're
a young
you're a young man that's trying to
juggle all this at the same time
yeah that's pretty wild so did you did
you finish school and then like move out
to los angeles completely or
no but i went for four years okay
so it's still open-ended yeah i don't
know how many of those years
counted to be honest i i left school
every second semester and i don't think
i completed a full year until
my third year whatever okay because the
second semester of college i was on tour
with whit
oh wow yeah yeah so i was gone for six
months
came back then the scholarship ran out
of money i left then i was came back was
auditing classes then i was there for
like a year and a half
then i got the louis show and i just
left wow
so technically there's still an
opportunity for you to graduate at some
point
there is
and i would just be like um i'd be there
because i just had friends there and
would have
yeah well so i'd be in the school and
inevitably there'd be somebody in some
office thing like
i remember somebody i don't know what
her job was but she was like are you
malcolm barrett
um and i was like yeah i am she was like
she's like hey so you you've left the
school but you didn't fill out
any of the stuff to say like hey like
for matriculation or for leaving or
officially like you haven't done any of
that um she was like would you mind just
coming into my office for a second
and just filling that out and i was like
oh hey look
um the reason i left school is because i
don't like paperwork
no yeah so it's gonna be a no
also i thought i thought you were gonna
say that she recognized you like from a
performance or something i was like are
you malcolm
uh i have paperwork for you yeah so
so you come out to los angeles and uh
you're doing were you doing theater when
you landed here or trying to do theater
at the same time as the whole acting
world yeah i have a theater company now
um
i know i'm yeah it's ammo yeah ammo
theater
yeah yeah tell us about that how did
that come about
well we've existed for about five years
now so when i first got here i
i was co-artistic director of a theater
a different theater company called real
theater works
um founded by a bunch of nyu friends of
mine um
and then uh you know it dispersed at
some point we were there for years very
hard to keep it up i was here
um and then about five years ago
a separate group of friends some the
same nyu folks came together and we
founded this new theater company called
ammo theater um and in a lot of ways
it's similar to the last one i had um
for good or for worse the objectives
i've had with both of these companies
were to have
a multi-ethnic company with women and
people of color in the forefront and
decision making positions and and
art um from underrepresented communities
and to be honest the goal of this
company didn't change from the goal i
had for my company in 2003
um which was to give more opportunities
to under-represented voices and people
of color and you know for good or bad
it's still
a relevant goal yeah no it's it seems
like
because i'm very curious how the
pandemic and quarantine has affected
the works and like the the theater as a
whole
yeah i mean it's it's a devastating
process right because theater
theater is not the best business model
oh yeah i feel like that's why i'm like
wow you're the artistic director of a
non-profit theater like
that still is a thing you can do that's
wild like
i've existed on the internet for the
last decade so
but i came up through the people's
improv theater in new york
and so like i still it seems like a very
ancient sort of uh art form now
that i'm i'm like impressed that you
guys are going and seem to be like
adapting to what the world is throwing
at you right now
yeah i mean it's interesting right
because in la improv thrives
right yeah but i don't know how much it
thrives because of like individual
improv companies i feel like a lot of it
comes out of the major companies that
are there
and the notes then get pipelined into
television yeah right
so there there really is even when
you're struggling as as say an improv or
whatever performer there seems like
there's a real big goal there yeah when
you're a theater actor doing stuff
you know the biggest goal is broadway
and you're getting shitty
right right right yeah it's still a
shitty day so
so you're really doing it for your art
like you're really in it to express
yourself
well especially if you've tasted where
you know me and you are going like
you're talking about being
in um on the internet and it's like yeah
there is a much better business model to
be a talented person on the internet
than there is a talented person in
theater you know yeah
simply because of ad space yeah and
simply because they're like people
aren't throwing an ad space at you to do
a play
um but we we adapted right like theater
theater has never been the major money
maker that uh film tv has been
um but it always adapts and and the
audience is still
has remained hungry for it since you
know since civilization began
you know um so it's still happening
there's about
we i meet with about um so i'm one of
three ads um
with uh julie brassani and kim hamilton
and we meet
every tuesday um about 50 other smaller
theater artistic directors
um to discuss the sort of future and
directors that we can do
and yeah what a lot of us are doing
is um virtual shows i mean that's
you know we're trying to do the model
you know what i mean
people can't make it out anyway so it's
just like please just pay
50 to do some theater
yeah so we do a lot of that like we
every
uh every second of tuesday i feel like
i'm getting this wrong
um or first tuesday we do something
called voices of ammo you can go to
theater.com it'll tell you more of the
schedule of things actually i should
that's a reminder of myself um but
um once a month we do voices of ammo and
it's
it's basically a talent show since a big
part of what we do is giving voices to
others
we have um every week hosted by
one of our ammo members um we do a
talent show with about five different
people
from all walks of life um and it usually
winds up representing
just all walks of community queer
um just people of color and and it's
things from poetry
to monologues to dancing our very first
one we had a dancer
cool and then in between it we have a
host and so we've also collaborated with
a lot of theaters with sacred fools with
iama
um to put on shows we could pass the mic
um where we'll do sort of 10-minute new
works
and then curated by
members of our company and and we find
that you know i i've done a thing with
play preview right they've been uh one
of the people in the forefront of
producing work via zoom essentially okay
and it's donation based and so um
we we've done our best to sort of revamp
that because we know how easily people
get
um zoom fatigue yes
yeah yeah yeah but so so this this
talent show that you do people can join
in and watch via zoom
they can watch well the talent show they
watch um on our instagram
ammunition theater instagram um and yeah
and so that's a lot
a lot of what we're having to do is
produce stuff that we've been put on our
instagram on our website
and on youtube um where it can live and
people see it so
what we're trying to do is always still
combine the live aspect
because that's what people love about
theater they they love this is happening
in the moment that someone could [ __ ] up
you know what i mean like watching
sports like it's
yeah watching sports the day after
yeah yeah a hundred percent it's like
going to see
a nascar in a way they want to see
the oh yeah the bobbles the the mistakes
the flubs the all of it
yeah i'm curious because you're an ad in
a theater
company you've probably seen some crazy
[ __ ]
on stage does anything stand out to you
as like the wildest like experimental
theater piece you've seen
or like silliest because i mean i've
seen butter dance
the woman that dances on the butter in
the theater in the round and like falls
down
constantly and i think the internet like
redid that
with a song under it with uh adele
excellent yeah yeah that's like my
association i'm like that's what all
theater must be
that's hilarious dude is funny right the
craziest [ __ ] i've seen i mean
there was a show called there was a show
called puppetry of the penis
yes yeah i've heard of this never seen
it but i've heard of it
i never saw it was in new york when i
was there i mean blue band group was the
craziest thing i had seen at the time
yeah um but keep in mind i went to
theater school
right i saw a lot of crazy [ __ ] i
bet you know what i mean i've seen like
speaking of that butter woman i saw
i saw an artist
who was doing this character
right we would have these things to
create your own works okay
particular class we it led up to like a
10 minutes so low performance
and she had various objects on the stage
and she was sort of putting around in
this
vocalized character like not necessarily
a person just sort of
almost cartoon ass character at some
point
she choose an entire rod of gum
[Laughter]
okay big spits it into a pool of water
and then just puts her face in it
smashes her face in it and
the whole class is like trying to sit
here
and i burst the [ __ ] out laughing okay
i was like what the [ __ ] is it
in my mind in my mind here's the thing
right we take it
too seriously
we're not supposed to laugh at that
right
supposed to have a reaction to that then
what the [ __ ] are we doing here
yeah a hundred percent i don't know what
the goal
but it got a reaction out of me yeah
that there's probably some very
profound symbolism somewhere in this
piece but the
reality is yeah she just bobbed for her
own gum in a
bowl of water
she was probably trying to evoke a
reaction
stall word crowd i don't even know if
i'm using the word stalwart but it felt
it feels right
that's i okay that makes me feel good
because i i do have a deep respect for
theater
it's a world that i think is truly
magical very artistic but
i i do think occasionally it can take
itself too seriously so i like being
able to find the
the law worthy moments within all of
that
um did you say lull worthy law worthy
wow yeah no i know god i've just been
existing
uh inside my home on the internet like a
crazy person
my girl got to know it because i've been
i've been doing my own uh i started my
own podcast thing
yeah yeah tell us about this i will when
i write i put
f like i'll do f6 or yeah whatever
so i was talking to her and i was like
hey you want to watch that epidural
patrol and she's like
[Music]
it's the biz lingo that's how you get a
talk
uh yeah so you've started your own uh
was live
with malcolm with malcolm yeah
it's going live with malcolm yes you did
you did your research
i've got some notes you've got notes um
yeah i'm learning so much as an
interviewer from you um
i it's going live with malcolm with
malcolm um
it's it's essentially an entertainment
talk show
but it's also just an excuse to like
talk freely with artists i know
um you know and it's it's it's
it'll go from talking about current
events and social justice to
personal experience as entertainers to
silly games that i make up that
the guest has no idea about that i
usually make up
as we're talking um so there's like
three or four segments
and none of them are played um yeah and
so it started
it started twofold right it started sort
of when the lockdown happened and
you know all the people who are
entertainments in a lockdown like been
hard right
like just for actors musicians because
we can't
form outside and can't tour right um
at the same time you know black lives
matter was happening
and i'm trying to find my voice in all
of this because i'm sitting in a
house going [ __ ] nuts yeah
um so it started as a way of me
wanting to talk about artists i started
with my boy brandon who i have a band
with virgo nicaras and then with marquis
marquis richardson um who's an
antebellum
and dear white people and the reason i
went with them
first is it wasn't even to necessarily
talk about
society as much as it was about okay
here's a good friend of mine who i know
that we can talk about
super serious stuff or [ __ ]
or clown about anything i knew that we
could these first two people are people
i could go anywhere with yeah it's a
safe
respectful conversation yeah but also
people who don't give a [ __ ]
like marquis like he doesn't give a [ __ ]
and it wasn't any you know i think there
were a lot of people that were
quiet when things first started because
they were afraid of what to say
yeah so i wanted people who weren't
afraid
of what they would say and also who
weren't beholden to
having to speak about the moment but who
who who were who are always powerful in
their voice and who
always share that and so that's a lot of
who my guests are you know it's been
phil lamar and ahmed best and they've
met nicole brown
it's been people it's crazy those are
great people and i think it's really
cool to see
people that you normally see in a very
edited curated space be very raw
and unedited and very human
with you yeah i mean that was the goal i
mean here's the thing we'll talk about
black lives matter
but i'll i'll open the show drinking in
a bat
cowl
and we're all trying to figure things
out and like yeah
let's not be afraid yeah i think that's
really helpful i know for myself in
quarantine
obviously the creative brain contained
can go crazy
a lot of times and so i think it's
really nice to watch
people kind of harness that crazy and
like redirect it
into something like that and like
express themselves because
we're all unraveling a little bit in all
of our own unique ways
and so i think it's very helpful to
watch other people
unravel for good and not for bad
uh so this is something that people can
still they can watch the episodes on
your youtube channel and that are you
still producing new episodes
yeah every tuesday every every tuesday
at 3 p.m on my ig
um i have a new guest we took a hiatus
because i did
i made a promise to myself to do 10
episodes and do a re-evaluation
um so they're all available on my
instagram and then i set up a separate
instagram live with malcolm with malcolm
where i just highlight i have
highlighted sections of the interviews
and and promos so i usually wind up
cutting like
funny promos using sections of it for
like two minutes from them
so that's where all of that goes and
then i put them on my youtube and i'm
i'm on youtube now and so now
yeah because of the consistency of that
i'm building a more of an audience i
used to didn't give a [ __ ] because i was
an actor and so
yeah um well
i wanna okay we're gonna take a quick
break but when we get back i wanna learn
all about
your uh relationship with social media
so we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
all of those good dreams you're having
are about to become
great realities if you use some
squarespace squarespace makes it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
and i'm sure you've got at least one or
two rolling around rattling around in
your brain cave
over the last couple months if you're
trying to start a new business are you
trying to showcase some work do you want
to publish some content
or sell products of any kind or more
squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with a few clicks
so you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself
they also have powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics to help
you grow your site
in real time and everything is optimized
for mobile
right out of the box there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever and buying domains
is super simple
but you can get the help you need with
their 24 7 award-winning customer
support
squarespace empowers millions of people
designers lawyers artists gamers
restaurants gyms
they help them turn great ideas into
something real and you can do that too
by going to squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
grace to save 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain
that's squarespace dot com slash grace
offer code
grace okay we're back in
with malcolm uh malcolm when i met you i
met you through
most how most people meet through the
valley folk folk
and uh and so i everyone
that i have met through that world i
just kind of automatic especially
through steve zaragoza i just thought
automatically assume that you're also a
like gamer
nerd internet person and then finding
out that like no you're a theater
tv actor i was like oh so
how what is the connection how did you
meet steve or valley folk how did that
uh that meat cute happen that's so funny
i assume the same thing about everyone
there i mean i
i am all those things that's just not
how i make my money
right yeah i just i know because i feel
like i've met so many people just like
in that world and i just assume it's all
source fed
sort of people yeah i assume everyone's
an internet
star yeah yeah yeah i'm just in awe i'm
like how did you do that
yeah yeah but so the way
that i met so the way i know all those
people is through steve
zaragoza and the way i asked argosa was
uh me and him met
doing a show called nerdcoit uh okay
which was um originally written by gary
whitta
um it was written in star wars [ __ ]
abomination
show animal crossing um or no he doesn't
have the show out of crossing but
yeah he has a talk show on animal
crossing um and he's had
okay oh yeah it's it's very popular i
don't know i can't believe you're not in
the know wait
is this in he has a show in the game he
has a show in the game he has
huge guests on like musical guests
and all these people and he's going to
have wow yeah
yeah that's so i didn't even know you
could do that now my gears are spinning
into
all different directions yeah yes yeah
check it out after this he's got
he's got i feel like he's had sting on
or some [ __ ] like that like it's like
it's
jesus hey um but yeah so he wrote
something called nerd court right
and so nerdport was a show an
affiliation with sky
bound who does walking dead all sorts of
nerd events
um and so that that whole world wind up
bringing all these people together
because it brought gary widow from star
wars regret
steve zargoza who's big in the
um i don't know what the [ __ ] steve does
uh
i know it's he's an anomaly he's got his
own world
yeah so nerd court was a show where we
judged
uh nerd issues so it'd be like who's the
better superhero batman or superman
who's the better
um video game icon mario or sonic um
who's the pastor
who and so it was almost done like a
sort of judge wapner people's court
thing
oh that's fun yeah yeah yeah and so he
uh he was like you know how there's
always the guy outside of people's court
that's like
yeah we're doing so steve with that oh
that's great it's given the play by play
yeah
yeah and then i was the judge oh right
yeah and it was a great show because it
was it was the
defendants and and and you know the
opposing sides it was always like
it was either writer actors comedians or
internet people and the internet people
was touch and go like it was
it was hilarious because it was people
who'd never
done a character or done a thing outside
of like
controlling their own edit yeah yeah
it's a
it is really a pandora's box of what
kind of personality type you're going to
get
outside of their own comfort zone yeah
yeah that's how i met megan and gabby
and honestly all of them were really
great people and i feel like i've
worked with literally everybody from
that show
since i stayed in contact or worked with
everybody
um but that's how we met like we super
we super got along during that and it
was a heavy improvised show too
like speaking about having like so my
background is theater
improv all of that and then we have
writers and we have
uh internet folks i don't know what
category uh yeah it's like
it's like the bipod letter you know when
white folks are trying to figure out
what to call black people
like nerd american
are you an internet an influencer
american yeah
that's perfect so
so it literally every once in a while
there would be a crashing bird
and it would i would literally just go
to the producer i remember one
particular one like we had wrapped up
the case because there was like a loose
we got a loose form in a loose script
sure basically
we're going to produce somewhere during
a break and going
do we have enough for a show he was like
no okay
right
yeah stretch it out stretch it out so
that's how we got cool and then and then
we stayed cool and i wound up doing
is uh his movie that i think they
produced reunion
okay martin starr and brie
and a guy whose name i'm forgetting
because i haven't really chilled with
him since but
he was great sounds great he sounds
lovely
yeah uh that's super cool and so that
kind of got you
introduced to like the internet world of
things
yeah yeah i mean it's it's very
interesting you're
but you also said the beginning that
you've been cast as a nerd a lot
but it seems like it's kind of in your
dna that that's
the kind of stuff that you are naturally
interested in off-screen
as much as on-screen uh you've been to
comic-con
how many times three three
okay what's your comic-con experience
because you've been for various things
and i've only been to comic-con once
and it's wild can i tell you i
in three years i lived the lifespan
of out of comic like you know
and by complete coincidence um
friggin i was there initially
either three or four times but i was
there the very first time i went was a
gift from my girlfriend at the time
okay i wanted a fan and it was the best
thing in the world
and i saw so much things and i think i
was doing a movie with kerry washington
at the time and so
she was there promoting django so you
know i think i texted her to get in the
room you know what i mean because i
still
that's cool like got me automatically
into places yeah
so like i was like i was like carrie is
there how do i get in
she's like i was like
that panel and everything like that and
i saw really cool [ __ ] and i got to be
there as a fan
very probably admit
the very next year the year after that
um
it was probably the year after i did
timeless and
that is how i got invited to comic-con
and that was
that must have been insane nerdgasm my
face was on billboards and buses
do you know what i mean at this place
that i was like once
just attend you know yeah and then all
of a sudden
because for people that haven't been to
comic con comic con
feels like it's its own planet
there's just like hotels wrapped in
advertisements
buses wrapped in advertisements like
flash mobs of advertisements it's just
it's kind of like idiocracy in a way
a little bit but there's and so i can't
imagine that just a year later all of a
sudden you're going back to this place
and your face is plastered on things
my face is plastered you know i'm i by
then i know a couple nerd folks so i'm
going to events
yeah we had our own ride
you know like the luxury of it all
it was crazy i'd never been in that
position
um and we had the panels um and then on
top of that
um so afterwards
i'm like the only one who wanted to like
walk the floor afterwards
oh which is uh for someone that's face
is everywhere that's like a
a very dangerous activity
yes it was very it was very different um
but my face was everywhere but people
didn't know who i was
right oh okay because had the show come
out yeah at that point it didn't come
out yet
oh okay okay oh it's flashing everywhere
and people don't know me and also people
don't automatically think that they're
standing next to the guy that's on the
poster sure yeah yeah they're like great
cosplay
well what's great is like so i'm there's
an instagram one of my earliest
instagrams is me
online uh to the gravitron
the timeless graviton standing in front
of my face
oh my god next to in line with other
people right
and like literally everyone's on their
phone because that's the planet we're in
and yeah i'm like i'm like whoa
there's this guy who's here and i'm like
you excited to get on the ride
he's like yeah like it's pretty cool huh
the show thomas was like because he gets
no idea who i am at all oh cool
you know what i mean yeah register yeah
oh that's so nice did you have any like
fan boy moments i'm sure down at comic
con did you cross paths with anyone that
like blew your mind
yes oh wait i gotta tell you the end of
this story hold on okay yeah
so uh so after it's after we do our
panel
and the other one wants to go out and
they're like do you want
security and i was like what they were
like
they're like you're on the floor usually
i was like i'm not
famous like that he's like and the guy
or or the guy and
he got there's something where he goes
you know we can sin i was like what
would that look like he was like it'd be
um
two would get two guards for you while
you walk there
it was like he was like he's like and
then we can get you a mask
as well you know so you can wear a mask
when you're going on
everyone like i said like if you don't
know where's masks and sometimes
there'll be famous people who have
things there who just wear masks while
they're on the floor
yeah i've seen the photos of brian
cranston like wearing a mask of his
so he's like he's like do you want to
wear masks and i said hey
if i wear masks it's going to defeat the
whole purpose of me walking around with
security guards
that's very true yeah
no give me this i want to see people's
faces when i live
out this fantasy right now and it was it
was
[ __ ] awesome and then and then i ran
into [ __ ]
steve and mike i was like where you guys
at i'm gonna hate you and they're like
okay
and we go and it's just they're like are
you [ __ ] kidding me i'm like yeah i
got security guards now man
oh that's so fun um
but my my biggest so it's it's a weird
the fanboy
moment is weird because it's like i work
with a lot of these people
right right right right um but a lot of
them are like i
watch a lot of this comic [ __ ] like the
craziest [ __ ] for me
is uh i ran into the defenders
like oh like we were just like going
through like it's one of those things
where we were both going through actors
sort of
elevators yeah and they knew who
and i was like the craziest or luke cage
there luke
cause all the brothers know who we are
so like i took i took a picture it was
and i knew kristen
ritter because we did a tv show um
so it was like me [ __ ] iron fist dear
devil
and then luke cage and [ __ ] you know
what i mean oh cool
so i was i was going nuts man i mean i
i'm fanboying each and every time i i go
to comic con
you know any batmobile i see any
comic-con footage i can see
i was there when zack snyder had
released the [ __ ] for batman versus
superman which i think was before
i was there at comic con and then the
most comic-con was great because it was
like
i got to go to all the parties because
timeless and preacher had
were happening because timeless was
coming back as either a movie or second
season and preacher i just joined at the
same time
cool so i actually got to go to a bunch
of like
little things and was on the panel with
them and then
you know so it was and then after that
the very last one i went with my blurred
crew a bunch of black nerds were all in
the industry
right now that's great tv shows and our
people at wherever the [ __ ] they're at
but um
we went as people like i went just as
guys going on a thing or on friends
going on a thing
yeah a couple of them had panels and i
didn't necessarily even have panels but
i was like there for the parties
oh i was there with the boys there we go
yeah yeah yeah
that's right that's right oh yeah the
season two is coming out
yeah september right yeah and i was like
begging kripke who's the writer of the
show and i was like
because i wasn't officially with them so
i was like can i go into these parties
is that can i be on the bus
i'll just provide them please please
um well okay this is a question i ask a
lot of people that are are
traditional actors uh do you have a
worst auditioning
memory yes i have a couple oh
i would love to hear one if you're
comfortable sharing yeah yeah they're
all horrible
they're not none of them are sexual
harassment or anything so like okay okay
okay they're just bad in general um
so the worst auditions i'll tell you the
three that come to mind off
off the top is uh is uh
one of the worst ones i had you know i
used to go in for the commercials a lot
there's definitely one
where people are just eating and not
paying me
while you're auditioning which oh god
yeah in a salad and like
a complex salad do you know what i mean
like they're they're picking things out
of the salad
yeah like there's different dressings
like i didn't
[ __ ] with this salad i'm so hungry i'm
clearly broke i'm
but i think one of my worst ones
commercial auditions are horrible
um yeah they're they're i don't do i
haven't done those for years because
they're just
like truly terrible they're truly
terrible and you really don't
honestly this is why i think improvisers
and comedians do well in those things is
because
they don't really they rarely tell you
the whole amount of information
mm-hmm commercials you get there and you
have a broad idea and then they're like
yeah so then you're doing this this and
this and you're like okay
yeah um and then if you want to change
the dialogue go ahead you're like yeah i
mean because this sucks
so i will but the other worst one i
definitely went in the forward audition
where uh where i
was asleep where i had to pretend to be
asleep
okay that was my audition
once i entered the room
it's oh it's so stupid
oh wow that's a bold move right there
i didn't you know [ __ ] half hour hour
to get ready
an hour and a half with the audition an
hour you know 45 minutes of waiting
thank you i you just brought back
all of the memories of how much i hated
doing that [ __ ] and i felt like every
time i was on like a hidden prank show i
was like there must be a camera
somewhere
there must be something hidden there's
no way that you guys are all cool with
allowing adults to come and do this
in front of you all day i had a
commercial
where they didn't tell me to like out
there um but it was like you're
you know you're a couple you're a
married couple testing out a bed or
something some stupid [ __ ]
mm-hmm and um i've been told that it was
like they're looking for quirky and
weird or whatever
so i wore this jacket that i always wore
whenever when i was being porky
right okay and i wear this jacket
and it's just me and i'm like this
doesn't feel right no one looks
nervous working oh no
and and then they're like yeah and then
somehow you guys make
out and you know after we've been picked
up and i'm paired up with this beautiful
black guy
she is beautiful and they go uh you guys
have to make it out and i go
we do i was like i just wasn't prepared
to do that
and look this woman gives me
like [ __ ]
you should be so honored it was
definitely one of those
oh i'm sorry surprise you got to kiss me
and by the way that was more my mom than
her this all of this
but she definitely it was definitely
looking like
yeah you get to kiss me and me i just
was like i didn't know i was doing
kissing today like i don't know
i wore my jacket this is not a kissing
my kissing jacket
oh man i'm happy to hear that you've
also had those experiences that we're
not alone in that
um okay we're gonna take one i'm
cutting you off real quick we're gonna
take one last break when we get back
we got twitter questions for you and
we'll be right back with more not too
[Music]
deep
[Music]
did you know that there's a company
that's mastered the science of sparkle
meet lightbox lab grown diamonds they
hacked a billion year process to grow
stunning lab-grown diamond stones in
about two
weeks and they're some of the highest
quality stones that exist
they're always near colorless always vs
clarity
always a very good cut and always eight
hundred dollars per
carat they come in three colors too
white blush pink and soft blue
after they're grown in the lab they're
transformed into gorgeous lab-grown
diamond jewelry
it's beauty meets brain go to lightbox
jewelry.com
grace and use code grace for 25
off that's lightbox jewelry dot com
slash grace use code grace for 25
off okay
malcolm before we get into these twitter
questions i'm going to ask you the two
questions i ask
every single guest that is on this
podcast
and the first question is who alive or
dead
would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at
i throw cold spaghetti at hitler but
that seems obvious
yeah we've gotten a couple hitler's yeah
yeah it's
boring it's boring hit lucy uh
i throw uh i'm not gonna do courage it's
i i throw cold spaghetti at the guy
who invented the material at the
bottom of your bed that you bend your
foot on that hurt
yeah whoever that guy did that
okay
most intense pain you've ever feeled in
your toe all right yeah we've never had
that answer
cold spaghetti straight to the [ __ ]
good okay why don't we make soft
material for the beds for the yolk for
the bed so i don't [ __ ]
hit my [ __ ] toe that [ __ ] hurts for
years
it's a trauma that i think more people
should be talking about
so i'm happy that you brought this to
the forefront of our conversation today
yeah i i have a book on me
who have stubbed their toe i love it
um okay the other question i ask every
guest is to tell us your worst pant
[ __ ] story
or close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases so
for example or a combination of words
and phrases
for example mine is college jogging
front lawn oh okay
uh all right
it's a very specific game it's very fun
uh i would go
uh
uh oh there it is there's the memory
yeah post college uh
cast uh
uh stadium for the jets
that's not
small phrases oh wow okay no follow-up
questions we'll just have to all fill in
the blanks there
uh okay here are some twitter questions
for you malcolm
someone wants to know what is the
dumbest thing
you ever wrote about the dumbest thing i
ever wrote about
yeah um
the dumbest thing i've ever wrote about
uh i used to write
these stories when i was a kid
in first grade and they were all just
variations of classic stories
okay that's how i started as a writer is
like
i think it's like it would be like the
story of the three penguins
and a bear and then the teacher was like
you might want to switch it up a bit
i like the idea of you as a kid saw
these classic stories and you're like
yeah yeah these are great but i think i
can make these better
i think i get that and that young man
grew up to be
a hollywood executive yeah exactly
um okay someone wants to know what's
your favorite memory from working on
timeless
um my favorite
memory from working on timeless was
um
that's very hard i mean every scene i
had with patterson joseph
i i think particularly
i you know look the memory is going to
change every day so it's like hard
sure sure but one of the things that
strikes me in this moment is the very
first time i got to rehearse with
patterson joseph
um who played mason who plays
essentially my mentor
and the mastermind behind the whole
time travel program um and me and him
just had a similar way
he comes from theater right um we just
had a similar way of approaching the
material
and so we very much approached it like
it was shakespeare and so we would go
into each other's trailers before the
scenes and
just go back and forth and play with
different things and and because
you know it's a tv show so you're
hitting for the sake of
new audience members you're hitting the
same beats a lot of time
with certain plot points and so for us
it was very important to do because
it just added nuances to things that
might have seemed similar or that the
opponents might have been familiar with
and we just
really wanted to make that dynamic rich
between us you know and we have we also
haven't seen that you know
i really was few and far between i've
really seen the sort of
two black men geniuses caring for each
other
in this environment and really having
these one-on-ones while still being part
of this other
broader story um so it must have been
that must have been really special it
was incredibly special for me do you
know what i mean
just to be able to be in that space and
they go toe-to-toe with patterson who's
one of the
best actors ever of our time of any
period
um he you know he wrote his own piece
he i i can't say enough good things
about it that's awesome that's really
cool and it's also really cool to
hear how much you guys cared about the
work
and also must have been such a fun thing
to vibe off of each other's like theater
approach to it because i'm sure that's a
little rare
to find that someone approaches it from
the same sort of
like theatrical brain that you do yeah
my favorite my favorite note that he got
from a
director one time because he there's an
episode where he finally
travels with us and he yeah this whole
take where he pukes whatever
and he get and the director goes so so
that was a little theatrical
but patterson goes no it was very
theatrical
oh i love that that's very sweet
okay someone wants to know would you
rather time travel
1000 years in the future or
or visit the closest civilization on
another planet
that's a good question thousand years in
the future close to civilization
on another planet uh i think i'd go with
the other planet thing
right okay because i feel like you know
a thousand years in the future is cool
but it's just going to be a variation of
us
yeah i mean like it's just going to be a
bigger or smaller cell phone
yeah all right um
so i think i'm going for the whole other
planet thing right like the environment
because it's not even just the
environment's going to be different the
species are going to be different the
climate all of that so amazing
terrain planet
i'm with you that i feel like there's an
opportunity to go
to a a a civilization that's a little
bit less [ __ ]
than our current situation
yes um okay last question
before we wrap up someone's know what's
the weirdest thing someone has said or
done
on a set that you've worked on were
there a lot of like
goofs and spoops behind the scenes on
timeless i know that's like the go-to
question for everything
people always want to know if there's
like pranks pranks i know
isn't that crazy that it's like you're
all professionals trying to make this
masterpiece come together from like so
many moving parts and everyone's just
like but did anyone like put each
other's stuff in a toilet or something
yeah i think george clooney's had a bad
precedent for people believing that
pranks
are always happening and they're never
happening because everyone's just tired
like oh yeah everyone's trying to do
their job
everyone's just trying to do the job and
go home
well then okay let me switch this up let
me ask you now
to come full circle is there a piece of
advice that you would give to a young
actor entering into hollywood or wanting
to enter into the creative
world something that maybe you've
learned that you would tell your younger
self
yeah so i whenever i give advice i try
to be very very practical right
because i need to know what they can do
yeah so
like i used to have this website where
it was literally
it just it was just a page of the
[ __ ] seven things that you initially
needed to know as an actor and it was
just like
in new york you get a color head shot in
l.a you get a black and white headshot
um theater training in if you go to
school is probably better than just
taking classes
you'll be more respected theater
training um
in in l.a when you take acting classes a
lot of time you're doing scene work from
movies and tv shows which is a very
different thing than doing scene work
from plays because you're playing a
whole character for like an hour or two
hours at a time
you want to do voice and speech no
matter where you're from um
i'm from brooklyn um and so i had a very
different way of talking before i took
voice and speech
so you should definitely do that without
actually losing who you are don't worry
you don't have to lose who you are just
because
you know standard american english it
also will give you the tools to
understand how to use
your voice um which is very helpful uh
that's so i've never heard that piece of
information that's
really interesting the fact that yeah
when you change your dialect or your
your the way you speak you could feel
like you lose a sense of yourself
yeah interesting yeah especially for
people i'm gonna say
i can't speak for everybody people of
color people like me who are from
brooklyn you know when i got to theater
school
it was it was it's all white it was all
white
and people with money and people who had
been going to theater school since they
were like eight
and five you know people who were the
children of
people who were running television and
tv and so they didn't look like me and
they didn't talk like me
um and so i think it's it's a thing
where people are like okay so do i have
to sound light or do i have to
not be able to be from brooklyn and and
all of that and for me it was about
knowing the words to use my tools so
it's like i still talk the way i talk
especially if i'm around my brother and
my mother
but i also know what i'm doing i know
about the diphthongs i'm using i know
when i want to aspirate i know
that i'm letting my tongue be lazy like
i'm aware
and so it gives me the tools to use what
i need to use when i want to be a
character actor which is a lot of what i
do i play a lot of different types of
characters from different types of
places i'm able to do that because
one my background i actually have a
background in high school from science
and math but i also
studied you know edith skinner's
standard american english and
and um you know speech speak voice and
speech so you know
yeah and and just you know and also
surround yourself by smart motivated
people
you know and inevitably you'll wind up
helping each other so it's not about
like
meeting a famous person who will give
you a job it's about being around people
who know how to create for themselves
totally i think that's all
super sound advice um before we wrap
everything up completely
usually when we do the podcast in person
we have a personalized fortune cookie as
a gift from us to our guests for making
time for us
but now that we're doing this remotely
we have a digital fortune cookie for you
that i believe
melissa emailed to you she did oh heck
yeah well you're welcome to open it and
read aloud your fortune
all right let's see what's up here
today's forecast predicts a thirty
percent chance of steve zaragoza
in bed in bed i mean if that
uh you know that anywhere right now
steve zargoz is currently in bed
[Laughter]
malcolm this was really wonderful thank
you for talking uh with us today
and uh before we go completely where can
people find everything that you're up to
online if they don't already know um
i'm on youtube you can check my youtube
i would assume it's malcolm barrett i
don't really know
instagram i'm uh verbal be rapping
um um verified and twitter i'm malcolm
barrett i'm not american and then you
can check my band
uh wrist our newest album funhouse is
out now
um yeah yeah the theme song from the
show
from going live with malcolm malcolm is
actually a song we we
wrote together called uh big sir uh find
me there
ammunition theater.com sweet
well thank you again this was very fun
and also
very educational so guys go check out
everything that malcolm is up to
and we'll see you guys next time on
another episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep
too deep too deep not too deep with
christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music